three days into the new year and we have
a few new laws on the books
bianca holman breaks down what new ones
you'll see in the state and how they'll
impact you
we might not have rang in 2021 with a
huge bang
but that won't stop new laws from taking
effect
here are a few that will impact most
nevadans first up
more judges the population has soared
over the past 10 years
so more people means more court cases on
january 4
six new clark county judges will help
reduce the backlog when it comes to our
health care
our country continues to fight the
opioid epidemic
nevada is changing the way it tracks
prescriptions for controlled substances
instead of giving patients paper
prescription slips doctors will be
required to send the prescription
electronically now ready to save a coin
or two
nv energy is reducing electricity rates
for southern nevadans by 93 million
dollars
when you break it down that means an
average single family customer will save
about five bucks a month
and unlike other states nevada state
legislature only meets every other year
most of the bills passed in 2019 have
already come into effect reporting
bianca holman 8 news